we knew that once kamala harris was  involved it couldn't really be that  serious and we knew that because this is  what she's like  it is time for us to  do what we have been doing and that time  is every day  every day is time for us to  agree this whole thing about the border  we've been to the border we've been to  the border you haven't been to the  border  i and i haven't been to europe and i  mean i don't thank you guys and my  pronouns are she her and hers she heard  her  she would look down at me and come on  what do you want what do you want and i  looked back up and i said freedom  you're gonna literally see the craters  on the moon  i'm telling you we must together work  together  to see where we are  where we are headed but also see it as a  moment yes  to together